I want to start by telling you what it's like to be at boarding school and get a
parcel in the post.
Now,
this is not something that happened to me very often.
So when at the age of 15,
a small package arrived with my name on it,
it was literally the most exciting thing of the year.
I remember it so clearly.
The box,
the brown box with my name on it,
half a dozen authors,
my best friends,
all really excited.
We're still in our pajamas cause the post arrived after breakfast.
Everyone jumping on the bed,
open it,
open it cause they were sure that the Swedes that'd be chocolates for everybody
to share.
So there I was,
uh,
turned over the box,
ready to break the seal,
but something stopped me.
The writing on the back code unfamiliar,
I read it with this bear,
Her Majesty's Prison Service,
Holloway London,
anxiety choking me.
I tentatively opens the box and a pile of letters cascaded to the floor,
all with the same for mania,
handwriting on it,
my handwriting or dressed and one person.
Mom.
Is there anything more devastating when the moments when something you've been
trying to hide and hide from reveals itself?
So all to see
there was an actor inside.
Did Caroline your mothers?
No,
no.
They're in our custody.
So we're turning your letters.
T you Yocelyn sailing.
Devastating.
According to the Children's charity,
Bernardo,
the UK charity,
children of offending pens,
he spent time in prison are twice as likely to have mental and ms conduct
problems.
They consistently underperform at school and there's three times as likely to
end up being offenders themselves
growing up as a black kid,
as mother,
as a daughter to her mother who was barely there to parents who never lived
together,
let alone were married as the sister to siblings who themselves were constantly
arrested to assist that whom had pregnancy,
teenage pregnancy,
all her taken into foster care
being cousin,
a niece,
two relatives who value teenage pregnancy and states dependency more than they
valued achievements,
education,
aspiring to succeed,
to do well,
to be secure,
to be free.
And that environment was a battle of extraordinarily difficult odds.
My name is Carolina Flanagan.
As you've heard.
I'm a coach.
I'm a speaker and I'm an author,
but I am extremely passionate about empowering people to fight and win battles
they think,
but have no where in achieving.
That day.
I opened the box,
I discovered a secret,
the secret to toppling giants to winning battles that you think you have no
chance of winning
and it's the single most important factor in my journey to date and every
success I've achieved,
we used to scrolling down here is the clicker isn't work.
It's also the single most important factor in helping me to succeed as a mother
of four fantastic voice.
This picture is amazing,
not just because it shows my lovely boys,
but because they have all four of them in the same picture still for long enough
to take the picture and actually looking at the camera and smiling and nothing
short of America,
Dylan,
Noah,
Luca,
and Maxwell.
So today I want to share,
share with you the secret to fighting difficult battles and winning
that secret is this.
No matter how hard the challenge,
how strong or opponent or how daunting the circumstances,
you can win that battle if you do.
One thing.
If you focus only on what you can control,
focus your attention on what you can control.
Balance is definitely a battle.
It's hard.
It's so hard.
In fact,
we almost don't even talk about it anymore.
I find when I go into meetings and I talk to my clients about balance and
corporate clients and say no,
no,
it's what like integration that uh,
we want to have a working agility.
The ones that was talking about balance anymore,
I feel like I killed it off cause it's something that's so hard to achieve.
You decided to just kind of brush it under the carpet.
Just for fun.
I did a Google search on work life balance in bed 5.6 million results.
I didn't look at them all,
but certainly the first page,
it was all about the end of what?
Life balance.
It's a battle of extraordinary yachts.
Why is that the way I said three reasons.
The first one is that work life balance is,
it's quite difficult to define and they won't give me a quick definition of
balance.
Work life balance.
You didn't have to print the right.
You've got the perfect definition,
then please come forth with that.
Anyone,
anything come to mind immediately to find in between to define an equilibrium
between two forces.
Brilliant balance in other words,
but what does that mean in real life
to spend as much time for those of you who didn't hear on your personal life as
you do on your work life.
Thank you for that.
What's her name?
Oh thanks for that.
That's pretty good.
Pretty clear.
Yes.
And you see your work and your home goals meeting a work and your home having
goals.
Excellent.
Thank you.
What's your name?
[inaudible] Nero.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
this is a snapshot,
but the conversation I had with the client early on this thing,
so you want better balance but work life balance.
What does that mean to you?
What does it look like?
My client.
Well,
um,
I want,
you know,
I want my life to be balanced so you know,
I'll feel much more balanced.
Me.
Okay.
So can we,
let's dig a little bit deeper.
What does it actually look like on a day to day basis?
What are you doing
client
well at home?
And doing all the stuff that kind of makes me feel balanced and at work.
Yeah,
that works.
Balanced.
Yeah.
I know I've got work life balance because I'll feel balanced.
That conversation is surprisingly typical with my clients.
It's quite hard to define and I think [inaudible] did a very good job of coming
close.
Now this is a problem because as research shows and you would have almost
certainly have heard if you want to achieve goals,
it really helps if that smart goals,
yes.
Are there specific,
they're measurable.
They are achievable.
There'd be enlisting had timebound research shows it that increases your chances
of succeeding in achieving a goal and it also shows that if you can write down
what your goal is,
you can articulate it.
That increases your chances of succeeding in even more.
What was the last time you sat down?
You wrote down we'll specific goals or having work life balance
lady in the pink.
Lots of the question first ever.
Anybody ever do that?
It's hard to define and that makes it even harder to achieve.
Gotcha.
The Myth of what?
Life balance.
The second reason why it's so hard to achieve.
No one size fits all.
What works for me just might not work for you.
You may prefer to work from home five days a week,
but perhaps your preference is actually to be in the office and there's five
days.
Get all the work done so that you're much freer when you're at home.
And just to complicate things more,
if you have children,
what works for you?
We're not sure.
Nobody young,
what necessarily work when they're older,
when they're teenagers.
So what does this mean?
It means we have to create a kind of our own personal solution.
We can gather together all the different components there,
productivity apps,
and the time management strategies and the wellbeing routines.
But the important bit is how we bring all of these together.
And there's no universal blue pen for that.
You have to find our own way.
So the third reason why balance
is this
and knowledge of the the biggest,
it's just the nature of the world we live in and the way we work today.
All those wonderful technological advances that have brought us so much freedom
connected us,
wins we could never have dreamed off in 50 years ago.
A price,
having the bay.
We are always on,
always connected,
constantly working,
constantly moving and of course it's the demands of our working environment.
Positive,
the importance of performing,
approving or value competing against our peers and add to that what's going on
internally.
This is the battle second battle.
This is the two trucks.
What's going on on the outside with work environment,
but also internally our inability to restrict it,
to control how much we use technology.
We become slaves to it and add to that even our feelings of I'm an imposter
imposter syndrome perhaps or just do a name need to change to the rest of your
night ambition.
All of this conspires to make it very hard to walk out of the office,
which off completely and enjoying the bits of your life that don't involve work.
I want to tell you three stories.
The underlying my message about how you can win this battle.
So balance a battle,
which cause I'm just explained it's a difficult one.
It's a battle against the odds.
It's the 28th of August,
1963 Martin Luther King leader of the civil rights movement in the 1950s 1960s
in America,
he's standing on the Lincoln Lincoln Memorial.
There are 250,000 civil rights supporters that in the crowds and he delivers.
I connects bench.
I have a dream.
Those of you who don't know or recall or that being was,
it was in dream for a quality.
It was a dream for a day when the children of black slaves and the children of
black slave owners will be able to go to school together,
contributing equally.
It's hard to imagine a more challenging battle in the one bang faced at that
time.
This was the period of of Jim Crow of state sponsored discrimination and
aggression.
It was the time of niching is of the Klu Klux Klan.
It was the time when segregation and hospitals on transport in schools was
completely wrong
and yet 1964 civil rights act is passed.
In 1965 the voting rights act is passed and although discrimination continues
today,
the battle for equality goes on,
particularly in America.
There is no doubt that those two bits of legislation which made it illegal for
people to be treated differently because of the color of their skin,
they were iconic victories,
defining moments in an incredibly important battle.
How do they do it?
How did they win?
Three things.
Four things stand out for me.
First of all,
they had a vision.
That's what's so powerful about this.
This speech,
the I have a dream speech.
It was rousing,
it was motivating.
It didn't focus on how difficult and impossible that vision was.
Will that dream was focused on what that dream would look like.
And I allowed you to go back and watch the footage of that stage and I challenge
you not to be completely inspired by it.
So the vision was there.
The second thing that stands out for me is they look head.
So they had a strategy how they would do this and this involved non violent
protest in the form of marches.
Citizens on public transport,
non violent protest.
Was that only ever been to the map walnuts and that's the key to that strategy
was actually saying not just this is what we want,
this is how we plan to get it,
but anticipating what the challenges would be,
what obstacles they would face,
and those obstacles were winning.
Very real
violence being thrown in jail.
Martin Luther King was arrested in 29 times.
They were ready for that is that they actually trained in how to cope with
violent aggression and how to stay peaceful.
In other words,
they were prepared and they practiced the skills that they would need to further
their cause and they checked on every time that were arrested and then released.
They would continue that flight.
The second story I want to share with you is a story
from childhood.
The story of David and Goliath.
Is everyone familiar with that story?
Hands up.
If you're not familiar with the story of David,
right?
You all remember the story of David and Goliath.
It's one the book of Samuel and it's the story about this fierce giant Goliath
and how David,
a small,
innocent shepherd boy with a single slingshot was able to talk or to kill this
terrifying warrior.
And so when the battle for his people against the fittest slides,
now it's hard to imagine a more intimidating,
daunting prospect.
How in the world did David do that?
What was his secret?
Was he just lucky really with one slingshot?
This is the subject of a fantastic book called David and Goliath by Malcolm
Gladwell,
and it Gladwell's seeks to challenge or perception of what makes us strong,
what makes us weak,
people who people and things with it would give an advantage.
And those things that we think as disadvantages and what's wonderful about the
David and Goliath story,
if you read behind the headlight,
is David,
that small weak shepherd boy,
he knew exactly what he was doing when he went to face Goliath.
He knew the Goliath was this big warrior that he would be debt out from head to
toe in armor on the day in question.
He carried a spear,
but I've carried a spear.
He had a sword and shield.
It was there in all his glory.
They did meet us.
He knew the Goliath would be slow cause his arm's heavy.
He also knew that the life was shortsighted because Goliath had said,
where are you?
Where are you showing yourself to me?
Show yourself to me.
The other thing that David view was that he was an excellent slingshot.
He was very good at this skill.
This is a skill he used every day to protect a sheep against predators.
He knew that that's still perfected,
was enough and one shot to topple the giants.
That's what happened.
The third and final story I want to share with you is the story of Viktor
Frankl.
Viktor Frankl is a holocaust survivor.
He died a few years ago,
but he wrote a book called Man's search for meaning,
which is one of the most extraordinary books I have ever read and I highly
recommend you read it.
It tells the story of his experience in concentration camps and his fight for
survival.
It's hard to imagine the circumstances that weigh more heavily that could weigh
more heavily against you.
The torment,
the horror,
the misery of being in a concentration camp.
How did Victor Franco,
and there are very few that managed to survive when millions didn't.
How did he do that?
What made the difference between those fighting,
fighting to stay alive and those who didn't make it?
And this question answering this question is the subject of Frankel's book.
And he came up with one thing.
Despite everything that was taken away,
everything physical,
the emotional torment,
there was one thing he discovered that could not be taken.
And that was his attitude,
his mindset.
He realized the power of his thoughts,
thoughts that he could control,
no matter what happened on the outside,
he would always remain in control of those.
And that is what he attributes to his and many of the others survival in those
awful circumstances.
So those,
these stories have the following in common.
They are all examples of people who faced extraordinary odds.
People you wanted to fight a battle.
There are stories of people who want against those us because they focus not on
the impossibility of the task.
How powerful and overwhelming where the odds are against them.
They focused on what they could intro,
focus your intention on what you can control.
I've already explained to you that that was an instrumental factor in my journey
from then to now.
It's just one small problems more bled in that journey.
If only I'd remembered that lesson,
that lesson that I learned all those years ago when I was a working parent.
We're not attend to clear.
We got late,
which is the law firm.
I was working when my first son was born.
Dylan was six months old and I returned full of enthusiasm,
positive,
determined to make a success of balancing my career and my new family.
Wow.
That was the first year of being a working parent was the hardest year I've ever
had.
I struggled the demanding hours,
the competition,
the air of competition,
the culture of presenteeism.
That awful feeling is the only non-partner law of male who was there,
who had a child who had to leave the office and run and be be there for her
child.
That feeling when I got home despite being exhausted despite having to log on
and keep going with my work and all the pressure I was on it,
I was,
I was under a work,
the feeling of home when I had to learn the ropes.
Coming to grips with being a mother for the first time and I was doing
everything at home.
My husband who I'm happy to say as much better trained now at the his career,
his life remained surprisingly on impacted by the arrival of our new baby boy.
It was the hardest year of my life.
I fought very hard,
but I struggled.
What was my strategy in those circumstances and that really hard battle.
I had no strategy.
I was just too blind to be able to even spot the things I might be able to
control.
That is I would focus my attention on those things.
I went from day to day.
My head in is spent putting out fires.
That's what I did.
I had a year of just putting out fires,
always exhausted,
always stressed,
always worried that I'd forgotten something,
that I was underperforming.
All these different areas.
Is it any wonder that that battle and it didn't [inaudible]
when my second son was born,
I walked away from a career I had been leading up to spend my whole life
building through the reasons that I hinted that at the beginning of this,
it took a lot for me to walk away.
I thought I was powerless
as up.
She's a Pulitzer Prize winning author and poet and she said the most common way
that people give up their power is by thinking they don't have any.
I know I felt completely powerless when I was trying to juggle my legal career
and getting used to being a parent,
but it turns out I wasn't powerless at all.
The book that many of you are holding in your hands,
I wrote that because I wanted others to learn from my failure.
My failure was to become your success and the whole purpose was to show you that
you are powerful,
that if you focus your attention on the things you can control,
you can succeed.
Was it a lunch?
I business awards lunch a few weeks ago and I found myself sitting next to a
partnership,
the partner at Kpmg,
and it turns out she's been playing rugby for the England rugby team for about
15 now.
I think she's recently retired.
And we got onto the subject of when you focus your attention,
how people exceed what holds people that succeed,
what holds people back.
And she said,
yeah,
of course.
She goes,
that's absolutely mind control controllables.
What she said,
control the controllables.
That was our mantra the whole time I was in the England team.
That's what we did.
We knew we could do nothing about the size,
the reputation of the opposition.
We couldn't do anything about the weather,
about the pitch,
even about the mood of the fans.
So we put our head down,
we focused on our training,
our attitude,
our mindset of preparation and that's how we went into our,
into our matches.
And that's how we would
control the controllables.
That you just love that.
I wish it hadn't been the mantra of the women's rugby team cause then I could
have had it as mine,
but it sums up just beautifully
and that's exactly what I'm doing now.
What I've been doing for the last 10 years,
I am controlling the controllables in my life from the time I wake up in the
morning of what I do,
when I wake up in the morning to how I get to work,
what I do on my way to what to what I say yesterday,
what I say no to who I say yes do do I say no to what I think about at the
beginning of the day,
what I think about the end of the day.
There are infinite number of controllables in your life and your job is to
control that
and that's how I
yeah,
not winning very well.
It's scrolling down on my laptop so bear with me.
What does this mean to you?
How is that useful?
How can this be practical?
I want to introduce you to the baby proof method.
Just that suspense disappeared.
Hopefully it will come back again.
The baby proof method is quite simply a framework.
But I prayed there to help my clients doing sat in that know where to focus
their attention.
No,
what the controllables are and what men can do,
how they can control those in a way that helps them win the battle.
The balance.
There are four steps involved.
So that number one is all about the picture.
I remember I started talking about defining balance,
knowing what that was.
Have a really clear picture in your mind about what balance looks like.
It's not enough to call it balance,
not even enough to say it's an equilibrium.
It's not even enough to say it.
So it's the same amount of time at work or at home.
What is your ideal version of balance right now for you until you are able to,
once that question,
the best tips in the world,
I'm not going to help you out there.
Remember Martin Luther King's vision,
his dream,
you need to dream and ambition of that intensity if you have any chance of
succeeding,
but it's not just about the the dream.
It's also about making that dream come alive.
Right,
so if you're living your ideal version of balance,
you are there for three out of four of your child's school activities.
You are leaving work at five o'clock at least two days of the week.
We down tools turn your phones or technology off all wave at age,
whatever your version of balance is right now.
You also have to have in your mind,
in your mind's eye what might get in the way of that.
What are the obstacles you might face and crucially,
how can you prepare for those?
How can you prepare to meet them,
which is that number two in the baby proof method is to prepare.
Preparing is all about asking yourself,
what can I do now?
What can I build now that I will need when the time comes that I will need
later?
The best way I describe this is I often use the metaphor of running a marathon.
Nobody wakes up one day and says,
I'm going to run a math in today.
Well they do is they say,
I'm going to run the London marathon in April,
and they probably say,
wow,
okay,
I'm going to have to do lot of stuff that's quite daunting.
Oh,
that's quite a big task.
But they know if they do the right training,
they get the right support and then practice
by the time that date comes.
They don't be prepared not just to succeed,
but actually to enjoy it if they've done the work.
And this is what the baby proof method is all about.
Having that picture,
like I talked about,
having a,
seeing yourself running that race,
if you are running around running that race and join yet,
so preparation is the but who support are you going to need and it's the same
with the battle for ballot.
Whose support do you need to get better balance?
Is it your partner?
Is it the support of your boss or your manager?
Is it the support of your,
of your mother in law?
Who support when you need and how will you get it
with that step in the baby proof method
is to practice the skills.
Thinking of David,
he didn't show up to face Goliath,
ready to throw a slingshot for the first time.
It takes practice and become an expert.
And the good thing is if you do practice,
you will become an expert.
So the practice that is all about looking at,
well,
what skills am I going to lead?
Very simple.
I'm going to need to be extremely organized.
I'm going to need to be very good at knowing what to say yes to what to say no
to.
I'm going to be mean to need to be very good at looking after myself.
What's my strategy for keeping myself healthy mentally,
physically,
already specific,
very tangible skills.
Things that you can be doing that make all the difference in the battle for
balance,
but that require perhaps they require you to get good at them.
And then the fourth and final step in the baby proof method is perseverance.
How did you persevere?
How were you keep going when not if when you reach a point that you want to give
up,
when things seem like they're too hard,
that inevitable moment,
Martin Luther King,
the 29th time he was arrested,
how does he convince himself to keep going to keep trying?
Viktor Frankl,
how does he,
despite every day all the evidence to the contrary themselves that it's worth
fighting for to keep going.
Picture,
practice,
prepare,
picture,
practice,
persevere.
This is something I do with my clients and I've created an online course to take
that all over the world so people can access this process that is so empowering
in a way that fits in with their lifestyle is really easy and I'm really excited
that Google are going to be piloting this course sometime in the new year and I
think Christie is going to talk a little bit about that at the end,
which is disappeared,
but she'll be back to do that.
But back to the present.
What can I give you?
What can I leave you with that you can start doing right from the moment moment
you leave this office.
So I've got one suggestion for you.
It's just one controllable,
but I want you to experiment with
getting up early.
What time do you all get up?
What time do you get up?
What time do you get up your headlines and chocolate?
Seven 15 what time do you get up at six six o'clock what time my daughter gets
off.
He shouldn't be
anyone else.
[inaudible]
eight o'clock,
eight o'clock.
Whatever ties that you ordinarily start your day.
I want you to get up
one hour.
This is the goal.
We're going to start with a smaller challenge.
We'll start with a smaller challenge to explain that in a moment.
Getting up early.
I love it because everybody gets up,
right?
We all make a decision about what time you set our alarm for.
We all make a decision about how many times we pressed snooze.
How many smoothers raise your hand if for some reason.
Are you sure he being honest?
Hands up if you sneeze.
Sneezer
I read a blog about getting up early.
It has been undoubtedly the most successful blog I've ever written.
It has so many damn book which shows me it's touching a nerve and I called the
blog when I first posted it.
Never pressed snooze ever and it had such a brilliant,
in some cases quite stridor reaction to it,
but it got people thinking because right from the moment you start the day gives
you that sense of making a decision,
making a decision about what time you get up.
Getting up early is a controllable.
Everybody,
let me tell you just re of the many reasons why for me it's one of the most
important controllable from my life.
The first one is it gives me me time,
that essential time at a time in the day where,
but the only time in the day over which I've attached to control it means even
if that me time is 10 minutes,
15 minutes,
I have time to think about myself in a way that prepares and allows me to be
available for everybody else for the rest of the day.
It is a me time.
That is so secret that on the odd occasion where I think,
Oh a lie tomorrow a voice in my head says,
how could you do that to me?
How could you take away the most important bit of my day?
I am in,
you can ask.
My husband drives him.
Had I have gotten to the point where it's so beneficial to me,
I'm almost incapable of lying and it is.
So how often important to me.
The second reason is it's a moment in a day,
every day where I can have perspective on that day,
on my week,
I can look,
there's some distance and say,
what's working?
What am I doing today?
What have I been doing the last few weeks that's working well for me?
That's making me feel good like I'm in control and what's not working?
What is it that I need to change?
And it gives me that moment of reflection to come up with solutions,
to come up with different things to try and trust me in.
Create the space for solutions and ideas.
Hey,
that's what you guys do here in create space for ideas for innovation.
You will come up with solutions,
different things to try
and the third and final reason is it helps to keep me connected with the big
picture so hard.
Remember the big picture when you're busy all the time,
completely working hard,
overwhelmed,
being stretched from one task to the next.
The big picture of this,
just the why,
why you doing this?
Why do you have a family?
Why do you care?
Why are you still working when you know that you would also like to be with your
family,
what does work give you and connecting to that on a regular basis.
It makes all the difference.
When I turn around my six year old and I say,
I can't come to this event today because Mommy's got to go and do this piece of
work,
but don't worry when I see it in a weekend we'll do x,
y,
and zed and I do not feel guilty about number of things that I say no to because
in my head always as a compass is the big picture is the life I want for my
children,
to my family and for myself.
There are just three of many reasons why getting up early is such a powerful
controllable for me,
and I want you to experiment with it yourself.
So I want to set you a challenge.
I've called it
the 30 30 challenge,
super easy,
whatever time you get up,
even if it is four o'clock,
set your alarm to get up 30 minutes earlier,
but there are rules,
no work.
This is not a license to extend your working day.
That is worse than lying in bed to the Loveman and presence.
No work,
no devices,
no news
sounds so simple,
very hard to do.
But it's a skill practice.
30 minutes earlier for 30 days,
the next 30 days.
This is my to you.
What would you do with that time?
Look at the big picture.
Think about the week you've got coming up.
What's working?
What isn't working?
What could you change?
What could you do differently?
Controllables ends with the step of the way.
Good luck and let me know how it goes.
[inaudible].